[Music]
daryl starts off this hour in california
hi daryl how are you
i'm doing fine good how can we help
i'm wondering why the saving for kids
college is part of the baby steps i
don't know i don't quite understand why
i should hand my
kids that
that luxury
just give it to them i feel like i fight
in the expectation that they can work at
it themselves
then it'll mean more and it'll actually
get them further in their life in their
career so i don't understand why that's
in the baby steps okay
well i i don't disagree that um a lot of
what you're saying is true
um
the uh
but i will put out
you can teach people
uh you yes if you work your way through
and if you learn self-reliance and uh
you and i are cut out of the same kind
of cloth i i don't disagree with your
sentiment at all
um
the other thing though is uh uh
i've actually proven
that paying for your kids college
doesn't ruin them
because i paid for mine and mine are all
three very productive
very ambitious
scratch claw
have good work ethic good character love
god love their spouses
take care of their kids and so on they
all three turned out so i didn't ruin
them by paying for their college but
obviously i installed the things you and
i are both concerned about into their
walk as as their dad
along the way
so that by the time they got to college
i didn't do that but are you under a
moral obligation to pay for their
college no that's not why it's in the
baby steps
uh if you don't want to under the
auspices of what you're saying i
wouldn't disagree with you i think
you're fine doing that
uh but right but i i would disagree to
say it's the only way they turn out is
if you make it make the road hard for
them
that's not true no i agree with that
yeah
well we meet so many parents who are you
know they have students in high school
and they wish that they could pay for
their kids education but they didn't
think about it in advance so this really
kind of gets people thinking early on if
that's a desire for them to pay for
their kids college education um it gets
them thinking early on you know how are
we going to do this financially how can
we save in the right way in order to
make that dream a reality and of course
it's not and not every parent wants to
pay for their kids education you know a
lot of people get scholarships i had to
pay for college on my own that's the
journey for a lot of people but a lot of
parents do want to pay for it and then
they get to the you know junior and
senior year and it's kind of a little
bit too late in their savings plan so
then their kids end up in a lot of
student loan debt that's why student
loan debt is one of the largest stats in
america right now so it's really just
trying to help students avoid that yeah
right exactly so i christina i would
both agree with you we both did the
thing i mean her her dad passed away
when she was a little girl and so her
mom was a single mom and uh so she her
only way to go to college and mom sat
her down and said we got to get
scholarships so she became the america's
leading scholarship expert in the
process and got a half a million dollars
worth and scratched and clawed and not
only got a degree but got a postgraduate
degree and took care of every bit of it
herself her mom didn't pay a dime of it
and it didn't hurt her it's one of the
reasons she's able to sit here at this
table at her young age because she's
because she's got the stuff you know
that you're talking about daryl so
that's all really really good and so i
would agree with you
that there is no moral construct that
requires them to be in the baby steps
but you would have to agree with me that
the vast majority of people
say
i would like to save something and help
my kid go to college and so we need to
give them a vehicle a place to do that
and order in which to do that and that's
why it's baby step five
but it's not baby step four you have to
afford it honestly do what
honestly i just can't it's not
financially responsible for me to be
saving for that it's two there's too
much else that i need those
numbers need to go somewhere else well i
mean i'm still 12 years out plus even
but there's no way it'll pencil out i
mean i could save some toward that yeah
well that's cool that's okay too
yeah but it's not there it's not there
to guilt-trip you say you're a bad dad
it's not it's not it's not to say you're
a bad dad if you don't
well there's no shame in saying you
can't i mean that's what my mom said to
me is like she just couldn't even
should i no not necessarily
it's it is not a moral obligation
and
to your point it's right now i will tell
you this
if you're going to be
the dad or mom that says uh
i can but i'm not going to
because i want you to
be able to to to hoe this row so to
speak i want you to be able to push
through this i want you to learn hustle
i want you to learn grind and the
lessons you're going to get from the
being able to pay for it are as valuable
as the things you learn if you're that
dad or mom which is how you started out
the conversation daryl and i again one
more time don't disagree with you what
you do have in that situation the uh the
moral obligation as a parent you do have
is you need to show them how they can do
it
talk to them about getting good grades
so they can get scholarships talk to
them about choosing a college that's
affordable not a super expensive college
that they can't afford talk to them
about studying something that matters
don't get a degree in left-handed
puppetry and then end up as a barista
with 200 000 student loan debt you know
talk to them about uh hard work and
working and working and working and
working and working and working and
working i worked 40 to 60 hours a week
for four years while i went through
school
and i didn't die from it and it's not
child abuse
exactly
yeah that was i'm right there with you
dave that was one of my thoughts is just
one of the best gifts that my mom gave
me when she told me that she couldn't
afford my education the fact that she
sat down with me after that and said
okay so this is where we are financially
i can't pay for your college but they're
the coach and a cheerleader exactly she
walked me through it she gave me ideas
she helped challenge me good luck with
that right sorry about your luck or she
didn't wait till senior year and then
saying such to be you
yeah no it didn't didn't do that yeah
yeah you got it you got to walk with
them and say okay listen here's the
reason i'm doing this i want you to get
some calluses on your hands here's the
reason i'm doing this i can't do it
here's the reason we're doing this it's
good for you to learn how to problem
solve now i'm going to walk with you
i'll help you with the problem solving
i'll be your biggest cheerleader i'll be
your biggest coach i'm going to push you
i'm going to love you uh and if you can
do that
then you know you may you may end up
with a really positive result out of
this with some kids particularly
but um and by the way all three of my
kids while i paid for their school
worked while they were in school
if because they were on a tight budget
and then a bunch of money screw around
with if they wanted to go do something
else they had to come up with the money
to do that
and so like my youngest who's one of our
top executives at ramsey today many
years later he's still the ramsey family
uh mattress expert because he worked at
a mattress store so anytime we need to
know something about mattresses we asked
daniel because he knows all about
mattresses he learned all about because
he sold the crud out of him i mean he
was good good mattress salesman
they they didn't like it when he
graduated because they lost one of their
best salesmen so um you know it doesn't
none of this hurt it's a good thing hey
hang on darryl i'm gonna send you a copy
of the book debt free degree and i'm
gonna send it to you free and it coaches
you through and coaches how to go to
college debt free
if your parents aren't paying for any of
it
and uh it can be done it can certainly
be done